hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
2020 dominated by a generation defining
pandemic
crushing economies and catching world
leaders by surprise
as well as a highly contentious u.s
presidential election
which continues to divide the nation
veteran journalist and fox news sunday
host chris wallace looks back
on a tumultuous year and how it compares
to other challenging times
in modern american history congress
inching closer to hammering out a covet
19 relief deal
expected to include a second round of
stimulus checks for struggling americans
new york's metropolitan transportation
authority chairman patrick foye
discusses america's public
transportation crisis
and whether he thinks taxpayers should
be bailing out big city transit systems
plus commentary from former white house
speechwriter and fox news contributor
mark thiessen
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm herald oravera i'm emily compagno
and i'm eric sean
this is a fox news rundown
friday december 18th 2020 i'm chris
foster as we look back at 2020 fox news
sunday host chris wallace says about
president trump and politics in 2021
he's going to be a major topic of
conversation a major focus of our
attention
and it'll be interesting to see whether
he's able to maintain that platform and
maintain that spotlight
when he's no longer the president i'm
lisa brady
as more covet relief gets closer in
washington
the nation's largest public transit
agency is appealing for federal help
subways buses metro north long island
railroad bridges and tunnels were
essential workers before the pandemic
and everybody
knows it now and i'm mark thiessen i've
got the final word on the fox news
rundown
feels like we're in a bit of an
in-between time in america right now
president trump has 33 days left in
office before president-elect biden is
sworn in
the coronavirus pandemic is worse than
ever more people getting sick
and dying but vaccines are finally
getting to people with 20 million
americans expected to get shots by the
end of this year
we've been speaking with fox news sunday
host chris wallace pretty much every
week on this show
a historic presidential election and a
once in a lifetime pandemic in the same
year means we've had a lot to talk about
in 2020
we thought this would be a good time to
look back at what we've been through
this year
chris says there's really only one year
he could compare it to
1968 this reminds me that was just
a terrible year the vietnam war was in
full roar
at that point we had two terrible
assassinations of martin luther king
jr and bobby kennedy uh tremendous
disruption in our politics lyndon
johnson decided not to seek re-election
uh there were race riots in the streets
frankly much worse
race riots in the sense that cities
after the
after the assassination of king really
started to burn
big big sections of cities uh
the one thing we didn't have then that
we had this year
uh was you know a huge health pandemic
but
the only year in my life that sort of
compares in the sense that you've
wondered is
is the country going to hold is the
center gonna gonna hold
uh it was 68 other than that 2020 is
is one for the history books and not in
a good way
uh from president trump brought out a
lot of political engagement for
from his supporters and from his
detractors was the highest voter turnout
by percentage of eligible voters since
1900 when women couldn't even vote yet
um there's like 60 like two-thirds or
something like that or eligible voters
voted do you think any of that
engagement sticks or is that unique to
this man
i think it's pretty unique to this man i
i certainly don't think uh
you know the vast majority of the people
that were voting
for joe biden were out there waiting on
line for hours to vote for joe biden
i mean you could see it in in the uh
exit polls an awful lot of them were
voting for
against donald trump and obviously
the 75 million people who voted for
donald trump i don't think many of them
were voting against joe biden they were
voting for trump so
so you know well over 100 million people
were voting either for or against donald
trump i'm not sure
that that anybody can excite that kind
of passion both
uh for and against and
you know i i think it's i have to say
i'm not sure it's necessarily a good
thing i understand there are a lot of
people listening who like
donald trump but i i kind of long for
the days when
you know we have a kind of more normal
relationship with the president
which is that he's not in our face all
the time he's not
on our minds all the time you know he
occupies a place in our consciousness
and in our discussion
but he isn't the only topic of
discussion and that's why what for good
or
ill and there was some of both with
donald trump it seemed like
that it was been not only for the last
four years with the presidency but maybe
for the two years before that when he
was running for president
i mean he certainly got what he wanted
in that
if somebody walked up to you and said oh
my god did you hear what he did today
you would probably immediately know
who they were talking about where that's
not going to be the case but that's not
going to be the case with joe biden
no it's not and and you know some people
are going to be bored
and uh some people are going to be
relieved
the really interesting question to me is
how much
will donald trump continue to dominate
the conversation because it's clear he's
not going away
uh you know and i believe these stories
that whether it's
between now an inauguration day or on
january 20th or maybe shortly thereafter
he's going to give every impression if
not say
out loud i'm running for re-election in
2024.
so he's he's going to be a major topic
of conversation a major focus of our
attention and it'll be interesting to
see whether he's able
to maintain that platform and maintain
that spotlight
when he's no longer the president when
he's you know a a
uh a defeated candidate for reelection
it'll be interesting to see i i don't
know i think for a while
uh you know he's just such an attraction
to the media
that you know we'll continue to cover
him and so that gives him a certain
amount of oxygen right there
but you just wonder how long he can keep
that going when he's not the president
anymore i
i don't have a good answer to that yeah
i mean he's raised
more than 200 million dollars for his
political action committee
since election day it's astonishing
there's no question about the hold that
he has uh uh
on on millions of people in this country
you know roughly half the country
is is i've never seen anything like it
you know and i've seen some pretty
popular politicians you know whether it
was jack kennedy or
or ronald reagan or barack obama
but i've never seen anybody who had this
kind of
of uh of of devotion
and and you know this kind of just
almost tribal allegiance
um you know our politics is different
our media is different that all
contributes to it
but but donald trump was able to to make
the entire conversation pro or con about
him
for an astonishing period of time you
know we consume news and we consume
stories and trends with with with
remarkable speed and if you know just to
give an example tom cruise
going going uh postal on uh on the
people in it on his
uh film site that'll be forgotten in a
few days
uh donald trump is not going to be
forgotten in a few days
people are going to love him or hate him
but they're not going to forget him
speaking of coronavirus and tom cruise
going mental um
that those people um we've talked a lot
about the politics of this over the past
few months the mass the shutdowns and
you've said to me many many times you
can't spin the virus but a lot of people
are still trying to maybe not
politicians so much but i still hear a
lot of people
saying that it's fear-mongering and it's
fake news
on wednesday of this week
thirty six hundred people died and
somebody did the math
i don't blame me if it's wrong that's
something like two people a minute
for every minute of a day hundred people
died in this country now
the in fact we're getting much better at
treating
the disease the mortality rate the
percentage of people who get
uh covid who then die is much lower than
it was in april when we didn't
know about ram deserver and steroids and
all kinds of stuff
but when you've got 2 200 000 cases a
day
versus 35 or 40 000 cases a day
then even if the percentage is lower the
total number is going to be
much bigger now i understand the
frustration for people
you know who have been through these
lockdowns and you know you you wonder
about the science in some cases
but you know they're just when you 200
000 people are getting it every day
and i'm not saying everything you know
you got to follow the science it now
appears schools may be safer and it may
be safer for kids to be in school
than uh than to be out in the regular
world
and you know i don't i don't hold the
scientists wrong for finding
new facts and responding to those new
facts that's what you hope they'll do
but the idea that any kind of lockdown
not saying every lockdown is legit
but to sort of dismiss any kind of
lockdown and say
this is fake news um you know tell that
to the families of those 3 600 people
who died
right oh yeah i mean there's certainly
the science of what and when and where
it gets locked down is certainly
debatable i just meant the
the debate over the seriousness of this
um now i know you canceled your
thanksgiving plans we talked about that
then dr anthony fauci on the white house
task force says he's not going to see
his kids over christmas either
you guys going to lie low for this one
too or figure out a way to do something
or just wait the vaccines are coming
well we're going to certainly lie lower
i'm hoping to see uh
i've got one son who's got three kids so
three grandkids that i've not seen
since february since before you know the
march lockdown they're up in new york
and we're literally talking about
meeting they're up in new york we're in
in washington meeting in philadelphia
going to an
outdoor park uh you know so it's not a
long drive for either and and you know
spending a couple of hours
outside you know and that it's going to
he it's going to warm up a little bit in
the east coast next week
um and and you know with masks and
social distance
you know it's it's tough you you it
you know it's uh you're too young to
have grandchildren but you miss this
terribly and as you get older you you
know you wonder how many years
not to get morbid you have left and so
you're really sad
to not see them so i want to go the
extra mile or in this case probably 150
miles
to go see them uh but is it going to be
a normal christmas absolutely not and
and
you know in that sense i'm patient i
just my feeling as we've come so far
we've been we've given up so many things
to stay
safe and you know why why blow it knock
recklessly when you're so close to being
able to get a vaccine
all this year i've been saying to people
whenever they say well i think we'll be
okay by
the summer or labor day or election day
i always say i'll take the over i think
it's going to be
longer than that but i'm now of a belief
with the vaccine
maybe by this memorial day 2021
things will be back to normal and you
know it's a long time to wait but it's
not too long
yeah i think that sounds about right to
me and something you said a week or two
ago
that these polls about people not
wanting to take the vaccine they're
already changing
and i think the people are going to
agree they're going to start running to
the light at the end of that tunnel
uh absolutely absolutely i mean you know
look i can understand people being a
little wary now and wanting to wait and
see
but you know is if a month from now or
two months from now that whole first
group which will be millions
have gotten vaccinated and they're
they're immune from the disease they
have the right antibodies and there
haven't been any severe reactions yes
there have been a couple of allergic but
nothing that an epipen couldn't
couldn't solve then i think you're going
to see most people say
wow i'm signing up uh chris wallace i
appreciate it um
merry christmas if we don't talk before
then uh host of fox news sunday
always a pleasure thank you thank you
chris same to you merry christmas happy
new year to you
all the listeners out there
this is mark thiessen with your fox news
commentary coming up
after a months-long stalemate senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell says a
deal on covent relief appears to be
close at hand we're going to stay right
here
right here until we're finished even if
that means working
through the weekend which is highly
likely and the optimism
is bipartisan even as the two sides
continue to blame each other
for taking so long senate minority
leader chuck schumer says it should be
a larger bill but we're all eager to
conclude our work
and deliver the relief that the american
people have been waiting for
everyone wants to see this get done and
soon
in congress though it's not over till
it's over and coveted relief
ended up running parallel to talks on
the larger spending bill that's needed
to avoid a government shutdown
in addition while sticking points are
now separated from
areas of basic agreement not everyone is
on board
with those basics kentucky republican
senator rand paul
isn't a fan of stimulus checks for
everyone
what could be dumber as an idea to print
up money we don't have or
borrow it from foreign countries or
borrow from whoever we have to borrow it
from and give it to people
who are still working it's a really bad
idea
he's also critical of adding extra money
to unemployment checks
both sides seem to agree more help is
needed for small businesses
but it's not clear yet whether one of
the hard hit areas we don't hear as much
about
public transit would get more help this
time that was
part of the epic lifeline passed in
march the cares act
now the largest public transit authority
in the country
says without more federal help severe
cuts including thousands of layoffs are
coming
on an average weekday the metropolitan
transportation authority would normally
carry
over 11 million passengers on new york
city area trains buses and subways
with more than 800 000 vehicles using
its bridges and tunnels
but as with the airlines most of the
passengers they had before the shutdowns
have not yet come back and they get
about 50 percent of their revenue
from customer fares and tolls the
decline in ridership
on subways and buses and metro north and
long island railroad
is orders of magnitude worse than the
great depression
pat foy is the mta chairman if you
measure from september 1929 which was
the month before the stock market crash
to 1933 which was the bottom in terms of
subway ridership
subway ridership and obviously ridership
was less than because there were fewer
people living in the city
but ridership on subways over that time
period uh
decreased 13 that was the the biggest
decline
at the depths of the pandemic in
in march and april subway ridership was
down
95 and uh
right now subway ridership on uh
long on the subways rather is uh
you know down 70 to 75
depending on the day in january for this
year the mta
expected a surplus of about 80 million
dollars
we had a 51.5 billion dollar capital
plan largest by far
uh in the history of the mta uh thirty
percent of the revenue for that thirty
percent of the funding for that would
have come from congestion pricing
on time performance on the subways had
increased month after month after month
i think for nine or ten months uh in a
row
uh record ridership or near record
ridership on
subways long island railroad and uh
and metro north and then obviously in
march the whole world changed
yeah i mean the good numbers
that you had in january is that a
reflection
of the decades long effort around the
country
really to get more people to use public
transportation was was that a function
of that
paying off so new york is unique the
city kind of grew up and developed
around the mass transit system
we carry about 40 of the uh
mass transit riders in the uh country
who are far and away
uh you know the the largest in uh in
north america
and it's been part of the culture and
the development patterns and the
economics
of uh you know of life in new york for
you know over 100 years
and the pandemic has made a lot of
people think about
what's actually essential as well and
mass transit
and mass transit workers are essential
have you noticed
a change in public perception do you get
more positive feedback now
we we do and first of all your statement
is absolutely right i mean
transit workers subways buses metro
north long island railroad bridges and
tunnels were
essential workers before the pandemic
and everybody
uh knows it now the uh you know arc
we poll our customers and you know from
things like
70 of our customers have never seen
subways
subway stations and subway cars as clean
as they are now
the regard in which transit workers are
held
is never been higher and that's you know
that that's well deserved
and transit workers you know literally
kept the city and the region moving
uh you know during the entire pandemic
how hard is it to get
passengers to follow the safety rules
how are employers
coping with that added stress employees
i should say
as a result of an executive order issued
by governor cuomo
it is the law of the state of new york
that's a right on mass transit you've
got to have a mask
a mask is the single most important
thing everybody can do to protect
themselves
and their fellow commuters and our
employees uh our employees uh
mass compliance is uh as close as you
can get to a hundred percent
uh we survey regularly our customers in
the last survey that we
did uh bus
mass compliance was very close to 100
subway compliance was about 96
we've been uh relentlessly marketing and
messaging that
uh you know mass are the order of the
day it's the law but it's also the right
thing to do
and our customers have done that i ride
the long island railroad in the subway
uh
every day and uh in addition to the data
my anecdotal experience and that of my
colleagues at the mta
and friends and family who ride you
rarely see
a customer on a subway car or long
island railroad or metro north who
doesn't have a mask on
and that's that's really important and a
credit to the
work that new yorkers have done uh you
know collectively to stop the spread of
the virus
how much federal aid are you hoping for
i know that some federal aid is assumed
in the budget proposal that was just
recently passed
are you hoping for more than that or
just that amount
where where does the hole in the budget
stand in april
uh the cares act uh passed and that had
3.9 billion dollars for the mta
uh we because of the precipitous decline
in in our revenues caused by the
pandemic we exhausted the last of that
funding july 24th
literally three months later uh we are
our ask of the federal government now is
a total of 12 billion dollars
that's over a period of years which
would include
21 22 23 and 24.
the we're encouraged by the fact that
there are
uh serious and late stage negotiations
going on in washington with respect to a
lame
duck session covet relief bill which
would
include uh 15 billion dollars or north
of that for transit
around the country and approximately 4.5
billion dollars
for the uh for the mta to get us through
2021. the budget that uh you're quite
right that our board unanimously passed
assumes
that in uh this lame duck session or
early next year
we'll get uh on the order of 4.5
billion dollars that will cover the
deficit in in 2021
and if that happy event were to happen
we would not be forced to
reduce service dramatically on subways
buses
and metro north and the commuter rails
up to 50
on the commuter rails up to 40 percent
on subways and buses
and lay off uh thousands of uh thousands
of our colleagues
but that funding will get us through uh
only 2021.
what would you say to someone in any
other part of the country
who might think why should i care about
a big city's
mass transit issues and budget problems
and why
should my tax dollars be spent on it
one is uh the mta's capital plan
literally touches every state uh
in the union so uh let's go to the
middle of the country pick nebraska
in nebraska subway cars are built by
kawasaki actually in lincoln nebraska
there are 2 000 nebraskans
working on that so subway cars for new
york city transit
and and cars for long island railroad
and metro north
the 51.5 billion dollar capital plan
that i mentioned
literally touches uh nearly every state
directly or indirectly including georgia
and florida and texas new york state of
course
uh but pennsylvania uh you know we've
got a vendor
uh in georgia called the fleet corps
there's a company called alstom which
operates in uh you know upstate upstate
new york and uh so literally
every part of the nation is touched
point one point two
since new york contributes about ten
percent of uh
national gdp a little lower than that
what goes on in new york economy matters
to everybody
uh in the country and the
economy in new york is really reliant on
a
healthy uh mass transit system you know
the third thing
is that new york is a donor state uh to
the uh to the federal government
it's taxpayers contribute more than
uh the state gets back and where the on
that
basis have the uh not distinction
but have the burden of uh contributing
more to the federal government than any
other state
so the uh deficit is is larger than that
of any other state
uh and there are states around the union
that uh you know from a
donor point of view are positive they
get more from the federal government
than
uh is contributing obviously new york's
ability to do that
would be significantly impaired if the
economy were impaired because of
a struggling mta certainly a lot to
think about and a
and a big weight on your shoulders to
say the least
mta chairman pat foy thank you very much
for your time
lisa thank you very much
it's the perino and stirewalt i'll tell
you what podcast dana perino of the five
and fox news political editor chris
stirwald dissect the ins and outs of
national politics subscribe and listen
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
mark
mark what's on your mind joe biden
promised in his victory speech to united
us here at home
and told trump supporters that he wanted
to put away the harsh rhetoric lower the
temperature
and see each other again well there's
one simple way he could show he's
serious
give president trump credit for the
stunning success of operation warp speed
on monday the first americans were
vaccinated against the sars cov2 virus
this is the greatest public health
achievement in history until now the
record for the fastest vaccine
development was four years
operation warp speed dated in nine
months critics mocked president trump
when he pledged a vaccine by the end of
the year
after the president announced in may a
manhattan project style effort to
develop manufacture and distribute quote
a proven corona virus hopefully by the
end of the year
unquote msnbc's brian williams
interviewed one expert who assured him
that the timeline was quote preposterous
unquote and that trump was quote potus
in wonderland unquote
while an nbc news fact check declared
quote experts say that the development
testing and production of a vaccine for
the public is still at least 12 to 18
months off
and that anything less would be a
medical miracle
unquote well we got our miracle how
the genius of operation warp speed was
the decision to run the vaccine
development process in parallel
rather than sequentially the trump
administration invested about 10 billion
dollars in eight vaccine candidates
purchasing hundreds of millions of doses
of vaccines before they were proven
clearing the away regulatory hurdles and
putting a four-star general gustav perna
in charge of logistics and distribution
the administration pledged 1.95 billion
for the purchase and nationwide
distribution
of a hundred million doses of pfizer's
vaccine which began this week
it also provided 955 million to support
the development of modernist vaccine and
another 1.5 billion to support
large-scale manufacturing and
distribution of the vaccine
it also pleasure to purchase 100 million
vaccine doses each from astrazeneca
johnson johnson and novovax
all of which are in final phase 3
clinical trial
this strategy was not without risks the
government provided
about 2 billion dollars to centerfield
and glaxosmithkline for 100 million
doses of their vaccine which recently
suffered setbacks
but because the administration spent
billions to buy vaccines before the
clinical trials were over
it is now able to distribute upward of
half a billion doses of vaccine over the
coming months
first to the most vulnerable americans
and eventually to all of us
as dr months of slowing the chief
science advisor operation warp speed
explained to me an interview quote
between the first quarter and the second
quarter of 2021
the most at risk populations will i hope
have been immunized
this he said quote should decrease
dramatically the burden of this disease
on society in general
because most of the burden of the
disease is on high-risk population
by next summer he said the worst of the
pandemic should be over
nothing like this has ever happened in
the history of modern medicine
so why has joe biden refused to
acknowledge it on monday night in a
speech hailing his electoral college
victory
he ended by noting that we had just
passed the grim milestone of three
hundred thousand coveted deaths
but he said nothing about the historic
vaccinations that were administered that
same day
it was like ignoring the moon landing
biden has criticized trump's pandemic
response failures
so why not give the president credit for
this unadulterated success simple
because that would mean acknowledging
that for all trump's flaws and managing
the pandemic
he is also responsible for ending it and
biden is saving that credit for himself
perhaps given trump's terrible behavior
since the election biden is in no mood
to praise the president
but it's not about trump it's about
biden delivering on his promise to reach
out to his opponent's supporters and
bring
americans together if he truly wants to
unite the country
he should give credit where credit is
due and pledge to continue
operation warp speed i'm mark tease
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes